your doctor may recommend an
arthroscopic rotator cuff repair if your
rotator cuff is damaged the rotator cuff
is made up of four muscles and tendons
that anchor the head of the upper arm
bone the humerus securely into the
socket of the shoulder joint
the muscles of the rotator cuff pull-on
bands of tough inelastic tissue called
tendons to raise and rotate your arm
while keeping the shoulder joint stable
a torn rotator cuff causes arm movement
to be painful limited or impossible
depending on the severity of the tear in
the most severe injuries the tendon is
torn away from its attachment on the
head of the humerus because blood supply
to tendons is poor a rotator cuff tendon
is unable to heal itself after a
complete tear and you will need surgery
your rotator cuff can be injured by
falling lifting pulling or doing
repetitive overhead arm motions such as
pitching swimming and painting in
addition the normal wear and tear that
accompanies aging can weaken and break
down the tendons
your surgeon will begin
making two small cuts in your skin to
access the inside of the shoulder next
your surgeon will insert an arthroscope
this device contains a light a camera
and tiny surgical tools the arthroscope
will project images onto a TV monitor to
guide your surgeons work your surgeon
will make a few more small cuts using
small tools to examine your shoulder
joint for unhealthy tissue and repair
the torn tendon next your surgeon will
drill a few small holes in your bone
we're an implants called suture anchors
will be placed your surgeon will loop
sutures through the anchors
and stitch them to the repaired tendon
to reconnect the tendon to the bone the
anchors and sutures will gradually be
absorbed into the healing tissues
at the end of the procedure your surgeon
will take out the arthroscopic tools and
close your incisions with stitches
after the procedure your shoulder will
be placed in a sling for support and
protection you'll spend a few hours in
the recovery room and will most likely
go home the same day